[Musique]
e
henri valeur bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle think ur view on
aurait voulu avoir votre point de vue
sur le journalisme les médias et le
traitement de l'information est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succinctement
s'il vous plaît je suis l'un des
fondateurs de l'association acrimed
action critique médias que j'ai animé
pendant près d'une vingtaine d'années
mais je n'ai désormais plus aucune
responsabilité au sein d'associations
avec comme mot d'ordre place aux jeunes
place aux jeunes alors maintenant on est
au 21ème siècle
comment avec votre regard et cette
expérience des médias comment vous
pouvez juger
le traitement de l'information en france
et peut-être en europe
ouf on combien demain pour eux portait
une évaluation de ce genre n'aurait car
oui non et non c'est un peu c'est un
sujet extrêmement vaste il faut leur
serrer pour que l'addition de la
discussion ait un sens
prenons un exemple ou affirmant quelques
bricoles
actuellement le journalisme de
commentaire écrase le journalisme
d'information
d'accord
le journalisme politiciens
écrase le journalisme d'investigation et
d' enquête sociale voilà la situation
générale du journalisme placé sous
l'autorité de chefferie éditorial
totalement incontrôlable et incontrôlée
on te prendre des exemples il ya
actuellement en france des mouvements
sociaux significatifs intéressant on
peut avoir leur sujet les points de vue
les plus divers est ce qu'il y à une
information des enquêtes effectives sur
disons les radios et les télés pour ne
parler que de deux médias en même temps
effective non non de quoi discutons du
dernier sondage d'opinion il y en a un
par jour à un an de la présidentielle et
du positionnement respectif des
différents candidats putatifs à une
élection où ils ne se sont pas encore
déclarés voilà une image de ce qu est la
situation de l'information une partie de
la situation de l'information
informer c'est choisir les choix faits
par les chefferies éditoriale des radios
et des télévisions pour ne parler que
d'elle sont des choix éditoriaux
contraint et contraignant qui évacue
pour l'essentiel il ya évidemment des
exceptions pour n'en parlera peut-être
qu'ils évacuent le journalisme
d'investigation et surtout le
journalisme d'enquêté sociale
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
carence informationnel c'est une
plusieurs choses d'une part
comment dire
ce journalisme de commentaires ne
s'adresse qu'aux gens qu'il est
susceptible de convaincre convaincre il
ne donne pas alors que l'information est
un bien commun aux acteurs sociaux aux
citoyens comme on dit les éléments qui
leur permet de se forger réellement leur
jugement on a relevé récemment pour ne
donner qu'un exemple
un article du parisien
plutôt à dossier du parisien sur la
grèce de la sncf
et dans ce dossier il y avait un tableau
qui essayaient de mettre en évidence
la situation actuelle des cheminots et
plus généralement des agents sncf et la
situation qui risque de des découler de
ce que l'on appelle la réforme parce que
vous savez que les contre réformes sans
appel des réformes de la sncf un tableau
et puis il y avait la question du jour
est ce que vous comprenez les cheminots
la réponse majoritaire était non
c'est évidemment un révélateur
formidable de deux choses primo le fait
que l'aco la question évidemment à deux
sens et non pas un seul
quand on demande un an vous demander ce
que vous comprenez la grève des
cheminots vous entendez est ce que vous
êtes compréhensifs ou est ce que vous
comprenez leur motif c'est pas pareil et
l'airé paul et jean répond non c'est non
seulement un constat de carence du
parisien mais ça veut dire que les
citoyens en france de son nom ne dispose
pas des éléments d'information qui leur
compère mais de comprendre quels sont
les motifs de la grève pourquoi
parce que si je prend à nouveau les
chaînes de radio et surtout de
télévision quand il ya une grève de la
sncf c'est 80% de micro trottoir à la
gare saint-lazare d'un d'usagers
mécontents excédé fatigué et ses essais
deux ou trois phrases sur les motifs de
la grève voilà les conséquences c'est
que les gens les gens deviennent cons ou
les gens deviennent non non parce que ça
c'est les gens viennent
à avoir une privation sensorielle à la
traverse et leurs médias s'est
d'ailleurs que leurs médias deviennent
aveugles et sourds et ça rend les gens
aveugles et sourds alors non si c'était
comme ça ça serait trop simple les
médias sont pas tous puissants
ils sont beaucoup moins puissants qu'ils
ne le disent qu'ils ne le croient ou
qu'ils le font croire à un certain
nombre de gens qui se laisse intimider
par la puissance des médias vous
regardez regardez une élection
présidentielle oui il ya une corrélation
flagrante entre le temps d'antenne et
les scores aux élections non non non non
elle n'est pas elle n'est pas absolument
flagrante et les toits sont six à une
causalité les circulaires c'est à dire
que le temps d'antenne sous réserve de
ce qu'il ya à dire des dernières
décisions prises par la majorité où
l'ensemble des députés limitant le temps
d'antenne dès ce qu'on appelle avec un
petit air de mépris les petits candidats
mais sous réserve d'un certain nombre de
choses à dire sur ce sujet soul et on y
revient
non il n'y a pas de corrélation absolue
par exemple le traité constitutionnel
européen
c'était un matraquage à sens unique en
faveur du de l'adoption de ce traité et
ça a été une majorité de gens qui ont
voté non pourquoi parce que les médias
ne sont pas la seule source
d'information des citoyens ou des
acteurs sociaux
tous les médias la seule ya une source
d'information qu'on néglige toujours
c'est l'expérience sociale que les gens
font dans leur vie quotidienne des
conséquences des politiques qui sont
menées alors évidemment quand il se
prononce sur l'europe ils n'ont pas
peut-être pas tous une connaissance
exacte de ce qui se passe au parlement
européen d'ailleurs comment le seul le
sort et il puisque toute façon dans les
journaux télévisés on n'en parle presque
jamais
bien ils n'ont peut-être pas une
compréhension extrêmement lucide de ce
qu'il ya dans les traités successifs
êtes bien qu'ils y soient favorables ou
qu'ils soient défavorables dans les deux
cas d'ailleurs mais il faut une
expérience une expérience et sas une
source d'information très précieuse des
conséquences d'un certain nombre
décision prise est ce que ce sont des
jugements absolument et totalement
lucide sans doute pas pas plus les leurs
que les miens ou les vôtres mais il ya
une source d'information ces voix là
quand je constate quand on va constater
si le taffetas là le traité
transatlantique vettel est adoptée que
l'agriculture française s'effondre les
agriculteurs ils vont se dire tiens il
ya peut-être une liaison ils n'auront
pas besoin de faire une analyse on
cherche à les prononcer des noms et être
désert avec les ya bien aussi
ici il faut pas hésiter
des journalistes qui ne voient l'europe
qu'à travers les institutions euro
tonneau européenne et qui se comportent
en chargé de communication de la
commission de bruxelles on va revenir
sur ce point là un peu plus tard je vais
vous demander avant de rebondir sur ce
passage des préconisations pour
améliorer tout ça aulas brown vous êtes
généreux l'a toujours rose une question
qui aurait demandé trois heures
d'explications sur l'état de
l'information est maintenant une autre
question sur les préconisations qui
demanderait à peu près autant de temps
bon alors je vais essayer d'être court
c'est comme ça on ne veut pas je veux
pas que vous soyez cours parce que head
course est tombé dans le slogan
idéologique pur le simple et court me
dérange donc je vous prierais de
délégués votre point de vue avec tout le
temps que vous on va dire un certain
nombre de choses très simples je
commence par une proposition qui peut
paraître inattendu c'est que on parle
des médias comme d'un quatrième pouvoir
ce qui ne veut rien dire
ou bien c'est un quatrième pouvoir par
rapport aux pouvoirs constitutionnels
exécutif législatif judiciaire
et dans ce cas là je comprends ou bien
c'est un pouvoir social dans ce cas là
c'est pas le quatrième c'est le
cinquième le sixième le premier ça n'a
aucun sens
en revanche qui est nécessaire c'est de
constitutionnaliser un conseil national
des médias et de tous les médias
parce que on a droit un organisme
fantoche et croupion le csa
fantoche parce qu'il est vide il est
nommé par le pouvoir politique à travers
des procédures sur lesquels je passe
bien et et croupion parce qu'ils ne
concernent que l'odieux l'audiovisuel
dans une période de bouleversement
complet des supports des médias etc donc
il occupe un secteur certes important
mais très limitée en plus donc il faut
un organisme dont l'émission soit
transformé radicalement et surtout le
mode de désignation
voilà une première proposition on l'a
détail provenaient revenait sur le mode
de désignation sur le mode désignation
que cet organisme au lieu d'être nommé
par le haut soit composé de trois
composantes très simple
premièrement les représentants
politiques à la proportionnelle à la
proportionnelle parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison qu'un tel organisme soit nommé au
scrutin majoritaire
que par ailleurs on peut disputer mais
ça ce n'est pas le propos d'un crime est
de discuter les modes de scrutin à la
proportionnelle
deuxièmement jeudi dans leur dos un bien
deuxièmement les représentants des
journalistes et des salariés des médias
jeudi des journalistes et des salariés
des médias parce que dans les médias n'y
a pas que les journalistes et les
techniciens un banc et troisièmement
avec un pouvoir de décision ou un
pouvoir consultatif parce que leur
représentativité au moins dans un
premier temps problématique les usagers
des médias avec ces trois forces on peut
comprendre ce qu'on constituer un
organisme démocratique et internet
oui mais tous les médias car tous les
médias que ce soit les journalistes et
salariés de te des médias qu'il s'agisse
d'internet ou pas d'internet
il ya un problème mais ceux là aussi
c'est une autre question c'est que qui
concerne les les principaux acteurs dans
le domaine des médias il ya un
bouleversement en cours dont on ne sait
pas très bien quelle est l'issue mais on
en voit déjà les premiers signes c'est
que on a en matière de propriété des
médias des médias concentrés dans des
mains de gens qui sont réalité très
puissant mais qui sont quand même des
nains
comparer la propriété des médias en
france avec ce sont les fournisseurs
d'accès les industries des
télécommunications etc et la puissance
qui est la leur la puissance qui est la
leur bien il ya là un bouleversement qui
est un bouleversement en cours dont le
dernier symptôme c'est ce qui s'est
passé à l'antre-2 de l'alliance entre
sfr et libération sous l'égide de dry
parce qu'on voit très bien comment les
choses sont en train de basculer ou
c'est en réalité le fournisseur le
fournisseur d'accès et de téléphonie en
l'occurrence qui devient
l'agent
important va être nuancée pour l'instant
de ce qui va être le contenu de
libération donc c'est à dire ce sera la
motivation de propagande deux de ses
fers aux non non il faut pas il faut pas
voir le rôle
on prend un peu de recul à nouveau après
avoir le csa on parle d'autre chose
dans le domaine médiatique comme dans
d'autres d'ailleurs
tous ne s'explique pas par l'économie
mais rien ne s'expliquent sans elle
voilà rien de rien ne s'explique si on
parle de l'économie
tout simplement parce que évidemment la
propriété privée et exclusive des médias
par des grands groupes non seulement de
deux médias mais maintenant d'autres
acteurs qui interviennent directement
dans la production de l'information
plutôt dans sa diffusion change
considérablement la donne même si on ne
sait pas exactement pour pas jouer les
prophètes inutile inutilement on ne sait
pas exactement où savamment fois on voit
quand même se dégager quelques tendances
fortes
bon évidemment les acteurs qui
interviennent dans ce domaine le font
avec des motivations qui sont des
motivations diverses ils le font
évidemment pour des raisons de
profitabilité
évidemment quand on s'approprie un
journal d fini déficitaire comme
libération c'est pas dans l'espoir de
faire des profits faramineux mais on
achète une marque et quand on les
intègre à un groupe qui lui fait des
profits eh bien ils contribuent à la
profitabilité globale de dison de drive
vous avez pas un regard du genre la voix
de son maître non non pas toujours pas
toujours à toujours et quand ça c'est
sûr qu'ils commun quand c'est le cas
c'est sûr qui par exemple bolloré
manifestement il se sert de la propriété
des médias comme alain outils d'
influence directe navas économique
c'est-à-dire d'un pouvoir de censure
d'un certain nombre de reportages qui
lui déplaisent direct matin tout le
monde le sait fait de l'art de la pub en
permanence pour les autolib bon c'est
une information récurrentes très
régulièrement vous avez la page sur les
de l'autolib qui se développe dans telle
ville qui at elle profite le cachons je
ne sais pas quoi enfin et c'est bon
c'est la page de pub gratuite qui se
présente comme une enquête du
publireportage peut piloter directement
par le propriétaire ou par ses pouvoirs
ses agents je n'ai pas de bolloré
s'occuper personnellement de tout ça
donc vous avez utilisation d'outils
n'influence
profitabilité outil d'influencé
économique on achète des marques qui
contribuent à la notabilité de la
notoriété du groupe qui donne une bonne
image d'acteur de l'information comme
d'autres vendent leurs collections et de
ça devient des mécènes de la vie
artistique et des non non mais vous
voyez oui très bien c'est en train de se
passer avec les collectionneurs c'est
arnaud et qui vient de fil des sons ses
collections dans un musée bon tant mieux
pour ceux qui pourront aller voir les
collections question mais il ya un
double jeu plus ou moins volontaire faut
pas voir des mauvaises intentions
partout il faut comprendre des
mécanismes alors outil d'influencé de
profitabilité economides influence
politique de marquage du groupe ça peut
avoir des motivations très très
différentes mais ça c'est des fêtes d'un
pouvoir économique et puis ce pouvoir
économique s'exerce sur les médias de
façon
indirecte quand je mets à la tête de la
chefferie éditoriale d'un quotidien
quelconque ou du gras chaîne de télé ou
d'une grande chaîne de radio un
responsable que je choisis moi parce que
je suis propriétaire quand je dis moi
c'est pas moi on a bien compris bon
évidemment je choisi quelqu'un que je
peux laisser fonctionner en toute
confiance sans être obligé de lui
téléphoner tous les matins ou de lui
envoyer des sms pour lui dire joffrin ça
va parce que tu as écrit la garde
prétorienne
non il fait spontanément ce qu'on n'a
même pas besoin de lui dire de faire
parce que s'il est là c'est parce qu'on
a bien voulu or cette chefferie y ait
ces chefferies éditorial conditionne
toute la production de l'information on
peut imaginer d'ailleurs on ne sait pas
seulement imaginer qu'il existe des
jeunes journalistes ou des moins jeunes
qui voudraient enquêter
tu voudrais enquêter qui parfois font
des enquêtes mais les priorités
éditoriales
les angles ce la hiérarchisation de
l'information
les angles sous lequel on traite et on
présente les sujets échappe peu presque
totalement à leur contrôle quand un
journaliste on lui dit coco tu allais
faire parce que comme ça on dira
chérif ya plusieurs reprises non je
plaisante coco tu vas faire un micro
trottoir à la gare saint lazare
dans un pays où l'on se fier au lance
pierre et avoir tes amis le soir où ils
vivent
mais que même soupçonner quelque chose
tiens est-ce qu'on peut aborder le jeu
boite engins étaient c est sa propriété
des médias évidemment aux sections du
journalisme pour l'appropriation des
mélanomes parce que je la suite dans les
idées un soir j'ai dit tous nos toutous
ne s'explique pas par l'économie mais
rien ne s'expliquent sans lg et données
de trois indices oriane s'explique sans
elle pourquoi tout ne s'explique pas par
l'économie parce que ce qui se passe
dans le monde des médias parce qu'on va
dire comme ça pour faire simple par le
prisme de ce que sont les métiers du
journalisme c'est à dire qu'ils sont par
leur formation leur origine sociale leur
disponibilité
leur habitude leur comportement c'est
quoi ce milieu social à travers lequel
est produite l'information on peut
penser quand même que un certain nombre
d'années dé 10 côtes des théocrates ne
sont pas en état d'apesanteur sociale
ils ont des réflexes et des points de
vue qui même s'ils ne dépendent pas
directement des revenus qui sont les
leurs ou un peu partie liée à ça je
pense que s'il s'inquiète peu de la
précarité des journalistes les
journalistes soient pas des jeunes
travailleurs précaires qui vont se faire
avoir dit la loi elle conneries passe
mais elle passera pas bien oui
continuez continuez vous sentez vous
c'était la page slogan d'accord ne
passera pas ça veut dire il faut pas
qu'elles passent mais effectivement il
ya un gros risque qu'elle passe quand
même
donc
évidemment ce que signifie la précarité
ils en ont une vision je ne valide en
aucune mais ils en ont une vision
totalement anecdotique quand par exemple
vous entendez des journalistes enfin
plutôt des présentateurs interviewer la
crème du journal des speakerines pour
nous voilà dire que
les cheminots ne sont pas concernées par
par la loi elle comme riz ou même les
lycéens y en a même un qui a sorti ça
ils sont pas concernés puisqu'ils
échappent pas de travail en quoi en ce
moment il faut quand même un niveau d'
aveuglement jeu et d'auto aveuglement
d'ailleurs sur ce que sont les réalités
sociales dans ce pays pour sortir des
âneries pareilles c'est peut-être pas
des âneries en fait
où est ce que c'est intentionnel c'est
ça voulait dire ne faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dit non mais je me
disais il ya peut-être ce sous-entendu
il y en a où l'intention propagandistes
fait corps avec le commentaire qu'il
faut bon c'est le cas notamment pas
seulement d'un certain nombre de
chroniqueurs économiques c'est-à-dire
que ils ont en effet pâti c'est ça ils
ont des chroniqueurs économiques pour
commencer donc se veut pas dire combien
j'ai oublié son nom de locaux commis de
nicolas doze rihanna comme ça claquait
bien qu'ils ont enfourché la vulgate
libérale et ils ont bien l'intention de
ne pas lécher les rênes quoi et donc ces
sites connaissaient nicolas 12,1 vous
connaissez nicolas doze à titre
personnel non c'est jamais rencontré
d'accord mais par contre il m'est arrivé
de l'entendre d'accord on va l'écouter
peut-être et de le voir à la télévision
alors on en était au sujet des wii donc
les journalistes la protection des
journalistes la journaliste ne sont pas
en état d'apesanteur sociale ce l'aide
pour dire que ce n'est pas mécaniquement
la propriété des médias qui détermine
nos contenus d'information nous ne
sommes pas stupides à ce point oui bon
la précarité des journalistes vous savez
les journalistes c'est comme des chiens
si vous voulez qu'ils obéissent il faut
les affamés oui je dirais pas les choses
comme ça mais enfin bon vrai mais il
faut appeler un chat un chat donc
revenons à la protection des
journalistes
les lucs slicks d
les whistleblowers qui sont amenés à
interagir avec des journalistes pour
faire sortir un peu d'informations la
protection des sources secret des
sources des choses comme ça est ce que
vous nous faire un petit éventail de
votre perception sur ce sujet-là au bol
elle est simple les communes il faut le
dire là pour une fois elle est commune à
ce que acrimed peut dire que tous les
syndicats de journalistes journalistes
comme et de
son prénom élise lucet élise lucet cet
après midi nous voir abba très bien
parce qu'elle fait un travail
intéressant ce volet a franchement bon à
savoir que
comment dire c'est ce qui se passait et
un véritable scandale sur la liberté
d'information un véritable scandale
quand le parlement européen vote des
dispositions qui sont votées en réalité
ans pour protéger le sécrétaire de
secrets industriels d'empêcher les
enquêtes que les affaires sur les
affaires bon voilà il ya eu il ya une
zone de non droit où l on parle très
souvent de zones de non droit 1 les
quartiers populaires c'est des zones de
non droit et c'est bon c'est même un
slogan qui fonctionnent assez bien dans
la propagande et politique et médiatique
lors qu'il ya des zones de non droit à
l'information
voilà il ya des zones de non droit à
donc ça mérite un zone totalement noir
oui ou sacrément grise zone de non-droit
là nous avons cette affaire sur le
secret des affaires mais une chose à
laquelle on ne pense pas toujours qu est
la suivante c'est que quand vous voulez
informer sur les conditions de travail
dans une entreprise
vous faites comment est dans la merde
moi moi en tant que hacker composé
d'actions comment les journalistes n'ont
pas les accès qui le souhaitent à des
débats de formations politiques de
syndicats d'associations du mouvement
nuit debout quand des acteurs se protège
pour avoir des conditions des malades et
de débat démocratique qu'ils contrôlent
eux mêmes sans être sous le regard des
caméras sans savoir qu'est ce qui sera
fait de leurs délibérations et qu'est ce
qu'il en restera on proteste nom de la
liberté d'informer de la démocratie
c'est même des germes de totti le
totalitarisme mais quand
l'information sur le lieu de travail où
les gens pensent passent l'essentiel de
leur vie est soumise à la décision des
responsables d'entreprises et donc vous
ne pouvez pas enquêté réellement et en
toute liberté sur les conditions de
travail de l'ensemble nos concitoyens
quelles que soient les entreprises qui
les emploient ou alors vous le faites de
façon marginale et de façon anecdotique
qu'est ce que vous entendez comme
marginal est anecdotique je sais pas
vous pouvez faire une enquête sur les
grands magasins bien et demandé aux
caissières de grands magasins quelles
sont leurs conditions de travail qu'est
ce que vous croyez qu'elles vont
répondre oui mais ça c'est au journal
c'est un petit peu de se sortir les
doigts du cul quand vous pouvez pas
enquêté quelque part il faut se donner
les moyens ou les hackers quand on doit
pénétrer un système et qu'on va faire
ressortir de l'information qu'est ce
qu'on fait on vérole ouvert où l'on
prend le contrôle et toutes vos data
nous appartiennent et puis après on pose
tout sur la table alors que oui mais ça
c'est de cesser la mutation du
journalisme simplement c'est d'un autre
ordre c'était un autre parce que là moi
je parle de quelque chose de tout à fait
précis mais moi je vous parle de
motivation je vous parle de motivation
quand un journaliste comme denis robert
va se faire 63 procès parce qu'il a
décidé un petit peu d'aller mettre les
mains dans le caca
il y va examiner son couteau pour
continuer à être vulgaire pourquoi les
autres journalistes on va dire les
journalistes qui doivent un petit peu
pour que ce soit un petit peu bar blues
un petit peu il passe sous le radar ils
deviennent un petit peu des truands il
faut pour enquêter sur des truands faut
être aussi un truand vous êtes d'accord
avec moi
oui quand il s'agit d'enquêter sur les
truands mais moi je vous parlais pas des
truands seulement on salaires et les
conditions de travail les conditions de
travail c'est
l'équivalent d'une truanderie sociale
wynn holmes et essayer de faire une
vraie enquête vous pouvez essayer
d'entrer dans une entreprise ou sur une
chaîne automobile ou dans un abattoir où
vous voulez un grand magasin en caméra
cachée essayer d'obtenir une parole
vivante de la part des salariés je pris
l'exemple des grands magasins ou
imaginer que les cacher de grands
magasins vous nous expliquer devant
devant caméra même si vous foutez leur
visage quelles sont leurs conditions de
travail en situation et que vous allez
pouvoir en situation voir comment ça se
passe et c'est çà ne sais je ne dis pas
que c'est impossible je dis que c'est
difficile mais il faut distinguer à mon
avis deux choses enfin sommairement
parce que ça se recoupent il ya le
journaliste qu'on appelle le journalisme
d'investigation
c'est à dire le journalisme qui révèle
des scandales mais pourquoi faire une
dissociation on a reçu les deux
whistleblowers
de canal+ qui sont fait un petit peu
blackboulés par bolloré
ils nous ont dit il n'y a pas de
journaliste d'investigation il ya un
journalisme point barre oui d'accord je
suis d'accord avec cette idée mais là je
seyed un temps avancé du une eau donc on
avance pas à pas en introduisant des
petites distinction pour essayer de
déblayer le terrain dont il ya ce qu'on
appelle tous les journalistes devraient
être un journalisme d'investigation j'ai
commencé par vous dire que c'était le
journalisme de commentaires qui écrasait
tout l'information et toutes les formes
d'alors en basse on appelait ça
journalisme pourquoi appeler ça un
journal parce que c'est le nom que sa
porte je vais pas dire que j'ai pas le
pronom un nom à l'est pas non souriant
et avec l'accent du sud du sud ouest et
cagole pas dire jean michel aphatie
n'est pas journaliste ou natacha polony
ou qui vous voulez encore je peux vous
en sortir une tête à chapeaux l'oni je
vais m en baisse est ce que vous l'avez
interview non je vais mettre un pas du
tout je vais mettre un bémol dans le
sens où nous on a quand même de la
chance d'être un petit peu jamais vu par
contre on connaît beaucoup de gens et
par exemple sur les réseaux de pouvoir
comme la commission trilatérale où les
bilderberg des gens que nous on côtoie
elle a eu quand même le courage d'aller
attraper christine ockrent et je vais
dire à mon sens c'était un acte
journalistique
franchement je ne me prononce pas là
dessus je le connais pas donc
quand je sais pas je ne sais pas ça
arrive à tous donc revenons à la
protection des journées c'est ce que est
ce que vous seriez david créer un fonds
de soutien des journalistes en créant un
fonds qui puisse permettre de les
protéger contre des procédures bâillon
contre ces gens ces choses là
très franchement je
n'y ai pas réfléchi et l'association que
malgré tout je représente ici à ma
connaissance n'a pas réfléchi mais
pourquoi pas mais ça ne ça ne résout ça
ne c'est une mesure défensive utile sans
doute il faudrait y réfléchir plus en
détails et c'est une mesure défensive le
problème ce sont l'ensemble des
dispositions légales
qui encadrent le travail journalistique
celle qui protège qui ne protègent pas
suffisamment le secret d'études des
sources et qui protège systématiquement
le secret des affaires de telle façon
que des scandales de vienne difficile a
révélé est-ce que d'une part bien et
d'autres parce que j'ai dit et que je
maintiens parce que je tiens beaucoup
c'est à dire les possibilités d'accès à
ces zones de non droit que sont les
entreprises dans lesquelles les hommes
et les femmes de ce pays passe
l'essentiel de leur vie et la plupart
d'entre eux dans des conditions de
travail qui sont des conditions de
travail allez on va être aimable qui
pose problème
j'aime bien votre amabilité et
d'ailleurs x trem habilité m'a fait
perdre mon fils donc je vais passer ça
fait peu après je vais je vais j'ai pas
l'habitude les gens aimables ça ça court
pas les rues oui enfin surtout quand il
avait huit de tf1
allons-y c'est parti alors à mon tour de
feindre
je vais vous demander d'avoir un autre
prisme de lecture ou de d'essayer de
vous mettre dans la peau de celui qui
défend le secret des affaires est ce que
vous êtes capable de faire ça ça va me
demander un effort mais je le fais aller
faire ses yeux c'est un test c'est c'est
un test vous faites une expérimentation
sur une souris d'accord je j'accepte
peut-être je me mets dans sa peau et
donc j'ai du mal un régime et doit donc
le secret des affaires c'est bénéfique
pourquoi
a évidemment pour faire des affaires oui
bon ça on a compris un d'accord alors
mettez-vous dans un contexte de guerre
économique absolue je suis de rage de
poutres âge numérique un peu trash c'est
un terme de hackers d'espionnage
économique
est-ce que vous pouvez aussi comprendre
que la france et l'europe vit dans un
climat de guerre économique dramatique
que ce soit pour les conditions de
travail ou pour les entreprises est-ce
que vous pouvez comprendre que les bras
cassés qui sont censés légiférer autour
de ces questions là essayez de légiférer
avec un gros gros gros bouclier est ce
que c'est compréhensible pas
compréhensible est ce que il faudrait
aussi les aider pas les aider qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors
vous m'avez demandé à titre expérimental
alors faites votre souris voilà
je vais essayer mais je vais être très
bref il faut mais il faut dès lors que
l'on accepte la logique est un imposé
par là parce qu'on appelle la
mondialisation libérale quand on
s'inscrit dans la mobilisation libéral
et je n'en dirai pas beaucoup plus parce
que si si c'est bien parce que je suis
ici quand même motif d'une association
de critiques des médias qui n'a pas
forcément une analyse exhaustive de la
bonne utilisation libéral même si on
peut penser que la majorité des
adhérentes et des adhérents de notre
association de non pas une sympathie est
absolument extraordinaire pour le futur
traité 32 transatlantique comme il
n'avait pas une sympathie spontanée pour
le traité constitutionnel européen pour
le dernier traité que mieux que françois
hollande avait promis de négociations
spontanément je crois pas que des
adhérents date mais en tant
qu'association de critiquer milian
n'avons pas à prendre position de façon
exhaustive argumenté sur ce on a déjà ce
boulot comme ça vient mais vous m'avez
soumis à un test j'accepte être si on
accepte le contexte de la guerre
économique et de ses modalités actuelles
alors je peux comprendre puisque vous
faites de moi un capitaine d'industrie
et même peut-être un actionnaire ah oui
ici
ou bien rentiers un rentier ou n'importe
quoi qui jouant ce rôle là on sujet cei
bon je vous comprends très bien qu'ils
essaient de protéger le secret des
affaires mis au secret des affaires et
secret des affaires
il ya le secret industriel
ça
toujours dans la même optique je
continue à jouer à la souris
dans une optique de guerre économique le
secret industriel qu'on le protège je
peux comprendre enfin je crois pas que
cache investigations pour prendre une
émission grand public qui fait un job
discutable mais plutôt intéressant ben
on
se préoccupe de violer le secret
industriel
et puis il ya le secret des affaires
c'est-à-dire des salles à faire c'est à
dire des paradis fiscaux
c'est ça veut des conflits d'intérêts
entre l'industrie pharmaceutique
et
les lobbys industriels en tout genre
toutes ces aspects là ça c'est autre
chose c'est pas le secret industriel
c'est le secret de la magouille et
malgré tout mon effort pour me déguiser
en ce1 en sourit je fais partie de ces
de ces industrieux industriels qui
pensent que faut nettoyer les écuries
d'augias mais apparemment je fais partie
d'une très minoritaire minorité de gens
que vous auquel vous m'avez invité à
m'identifier très provisoirement c'est
fini parce qu'au delà je risque de
souffrir
alors on va on va passer à un autre
sujet
qu'est ce que vous pensez des douars
snowdon
qu'est ce que j'en pense je pense que
tout mon enfance il est bien ce type là
voilà point qu'est ce que voulez me
faire dire de plus alors qu'est ce que
vous pensez maman de michel sapin qui
dit qu'il protégera les whistleblowers
les lanceurs d'alert jeu il se fout de
la gueule du monde un peu comme françois
hollande avec les paradis fiscaux
oui me lâche je trouve que c'est un peu
pire parce que ce qui s'est passé au
parlement européen
c'est que tous les partis politiques à
ma connaissance sauf peut-être de ceux
du goût et c'est à dire de la gauche de
la gauche ont voté
là la directive protégeant le secret des
affaires tous les campus sont nationales
y compris le front national
au
parlement européen cavanna peut-être tué
par lol très franchement je ne suis pas
regarde aller regarder dans le détail le
vote des individus mais c'est possible
c'est possible il est un peu
imprévisible même s'il est parfaitement
prévisible
d'accord donc les whistleblowers le
monde enfin là là là je pensais que vous
allez délayé un peu plus mais on va vous
donner quelque chose d'autre ah oui
nommé de la nationale à vous méfier de
la doré pour souris mais voilà après les
graines sont alors évident c'est
tellement évident alors et c'est
intéressant de voir comment les gens
perçoivent ça parce que quand vous voyez
que les lanceurs d'alerté ne sont pas
protégés mais que l'opinion publique les
portes c'est un petit peu comment comme
la loi travail des choses comme ça c'est
leur seule l'opinion publique n'est plus
écouté
oui mais là aussi je sors un tout petit
peu du rôle que peut assigner une
association de critiques des médias
il ya des formes de haine de la
démocratie pour utiliser un titre de
chaque rancière qui se répandent comme
une traînée de poudre de pau 2 une
traînée de poudre à
et cette haine de la démocratie
elle prend très souvent la forme d'une
haine de l'information s'inscrit parfois
des journalistes ou plus haut taux des
zi tôt crac des tests l'information on
en est là
on en est là c'est à dire on en est à
des commentateurs qui détestent informer
si vous voulez que je vous donne des
exemples récents à des noms sur tous les
noms les nous on sait pas le plus
important du genre je suis enfin à baho
fout pas d'airé je tiens je prends un
exemple à pauline de mahler bfm tv hier
à lui reprocher un exemple ce pas elle
personnellement je ne connais pas bon et
on ne s'intéresse pas aux personnes en
tant que personne ne s'intéresse à ce
qu'il représente ce qui est autre chose
et on essaie de le faire sentir bien on
est mû par aucune haine particulière que
vis-à-vis des l'individu en tant
qu'individu par contre les personnages
sociaux il nous intéresse
vous avez un certain nombre comme on dit
d'affrontements à l'occasion des
manifestations
qu'est ce qui est important
il faut poser question nano mais
sur laquelle on peut se teinter roger
premièrement ce qui est important c'est
les manifestations c'est bien d'accord
donc la place qui est donnée à
l'information c'est pourquoi les gens
sont mobilisés pourquoi ils manifestent
qu'est ce qu'il pense et cetera
niveau des micro trottoirs
les 28 avril et 1er mai zéro quasiment
zéro simplement ben un bandeau qui vous
donne le chiffre des mânes du nombre de
manifestants selon la préfecture et
selon les organisateurs
mais il ya quelque chose qui est non
moins significative qui sont les
affrontements alors là on y va on a des
images spectaculaires et on est d
interlocuteur
quel interlocuteur on a je dépends dans
l'ordre où ils me viennent les syndicats
de policiers bon qui sont pas
franchement content de ce qui arrive aux
policiers et ça peut se comprendre c'est
leur job on met aussi et des syndicats
de policiers que le cgt police
absolument récemment qu'ils ont pris une
position tout à fait mais
la préfecture de police
les experts va à les experts les experts
en maintien dors bien
les représentants politiques de la
majorité et de l'opposition
et il ya une question
qui est très peu poser
une simple
dans quelle mesure
les dispositions qui ont été prises par
la police
et les mesures et ce qu'ils ont fait
dans le cours des manifestations
d'une part au lieu d'empêcher les
affrontements les ont favorisé par quels
moyens abbas est très sain pour ce peut
se demander une question qu'on peut se
poser jeu là je me déguise un
journaliste je vais vous demander
d'oeuver l'église et bientôt en policier
méfiez vous quand je peux je peux vous
voyez je me prête à tous les jeux vous
mais on peut se demander par exemple
si en coupe en deux une manifestation et
en mettant des cordons de policiers
directement au contact des manifestants
on ne crée pas un climat de tension qui
est propre propice à tous les
affrontements parce que ça exaspère
complètement les manifestants eux mêmes
et c'est une exaspération que l'on peut
considérer comme légitime parce que
c'est pas fait exprès à moi de
tout titre d'un critique des médias je
ne me au titre d'henri malheur à moi
même je pense que c'est vrai sens devant
à partie intentionnelle parce qu'une
expérience des forces de police en
matière de ce qu'on appelle le maintien
d'ordre qui est suffisante pour savoir
que ce que ce qui est fait c'est pas
pour favoriser ce avec la france c'est
pas pour favoriser s'cusez moi c'est pas
pour favoriser des affrontements en tant
que tel c'est pour entretenir la tension
mais parce que la entretenir l'attention
sur ces questions là c'est une façon
faussement habile mais délibéré me
semble t'il
d'essayer d'étouffer le mouvement qui
contexte la loi travail et qu'ils
contestent au delà de la loi travail si
j'ai bien compris mais bon nous semble
que est ce que c'est une convergence des
luttes or vous posez des questions qui
déborde la critique des médias j'en sais
rien je sais qu'un certain nombre
d'acteurs et essaie de faire travailler
dans le sens de la convergence des
luttes je sais surtout que ce que les
acteurs en question se pose comme
question ne figurera pas au journal
télévisé de 20 heures ou même sur les
chaînes en continu qui disposent d'un
temps d'antenne illimité pour me passer
en boucle les affrontements policiers
mais j'aurai terminé sur les
affrontements policiers
que la question est posée un qu'avant
que vous me déguise ion policiers
deuxième question
il ya un certain nombre de violences
policières qui ne se justifie même pas
par les consignes qui sont données par
les pôles aux policiers qu on peut
parfois on se montre compréhensif quand
on est journaliste et peut être nous
mêmes des policiers fatigués épuisés et
cetera il est possible qu'ils aient des
difficultés à contrôler ce que vous
problème ils ont des armes à feu bon
mais
vous avez une comptabilité de la
préfecture de police du nombre de
policiers blessés au cours des
affrontements alors on la met dans
l'heure qui suit
les organisateurs sont beaucoup plus mal
organisés on n'a jamais le nombre de
manifestants blessés on nous on ne
connaît même pas la gravité des
blessures bien sûr quand il ya un crs
qui est qui s'est brisé le crâne qui est
dont la vie risquent d'être mis en
danger ou un manifestant qui a un oeil
bon ça on le sait parce que parce que
c'est très grave les policiers blessés
c'est valve on connaît le chiffre est ce
que les journalistes enquêtent sur les
blessures qui ont été infligés
gratuitement pour utiliser ce terme un
peu stupide mère qui ont été infligés
gratuitement à des manifestants voilà et
quand je dis parce que moi je me situe
du point de vue de l'information 1 c'est
ça qui m'intéresse au titre de la
critique des médias à titre personnel je
beaucoup d'autres centres d'intérêts je
me dis voilà voilà des informations et
des enquêtes qui ne sont pas menées et
je suis convaincu
que même dans les chaînes de télé et les
chaînes de radio les mieux contrôler ou
les rédactions sont à la botte où il ya
un taux de précarité que fait qui fait
que les jeunes journalistes et c'est
tout simplement de garder leur stage ou
de terminer dans de bonnes conditions
leur cdd avec peut-être une petite
chance d'en avoir un renouvellement ou
d'en trouver un autre six mois plus tard
dans un autre média qui aurait
énormément de jeunes journalistes
peut-être pas une majorité mais un
nombre significatif qui auraient envie
d'essayer d'enquêter sur ce genre de
questions pour prendre cet exemple très
récent qui est un exemple d'actualité
lampant que vous éclaire si c'est un
petit peu la voix je donc
vous trouvez que les journalistes ne
l'inquiète pas d'une façon équitable sur
la violence est ce que vous trouvez que
les journalistes ont fait un travail
extraordinaire sur les agents
provocateurs qui a dans les
manifestations pareilles
qu'est ce qu'un agent provocateur aux
bases et ses tas de choses c'est d'abord
il faut le dire c'est d'abord des
policiers en civil bien qui porte le
brassard quand même ça ils portent pas
le nom mais dans certains cas qui porte
le brassard j'en ai vu une et une image
bon mais on va pas s'attarder que
longtemps là dessus il porte le brassard
police
c'est légal et puis un badge de la cnt
au bas de la jambe
alors il faut bien se camoufler oui ça
c'est de la provocation qu'est-ce que
vous comment vous voulez que j'appelle
ça
ou est-ce que ça va nous emmener tous
arrivera j'en sais rien du tout moi je
suis pas prophète et à cri mais n'est
pas une association de prophète c'est
une association sans prophète égouts
donc
ya pas de prophétie à faire mais on
porter un jugement sur l'état du
journalisme si simplement si de notre
conversation pouvait retenir sa
journalisme de commentaires qui a
tendance à écraser le journalisme d'un
verbe formation journalisme
d'information qui a tendance à être plus
politicien que social journalistes
d'information où l'investigation celle
qui parfois est
vivir dans le spectaculaire je ne dis
pas que tout est bien dans ce qu'on
appelle le journalisme d'investigation
il peut très bien y avoir une culture du
scandale pour le scandale qui a des
effets de dépolitisation qui sont tous
aussi grave que le silence comme le
mirror qui va écouter des messageries
téléphoniques voilà par exemple il ya
des façons d'investiguer bien où on
provoque le scandale ont fait des coups
on cultive le spectaculaire va tout tout
n'est pas indiscutable dans ce que
j'appelle provisoirement puisque tout
journalisme devrait être d'investigation
c'est évident dans sa définition même
bon mais ce qu'on appelle généralement
de façon courante journalisme
d'investigation et un journalisme qui
est un journaliste enquête sociale pour
ne rien dire de l'état de l'information
sur les questions internationales
économiques
économiquement fin là on a quand même
les chroniqueurs libéraux qui tous les
matins vous déverse la soupe du jour
alors on a vu récemment
un groupe de journalistes
se sortir les doigts du cul en créant le
comité orwell qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
qu'est ce que j'en pense à moi ce que
j'en pense c'est un propos individuel je
sais que il ya un copain d'acrimed qui
se fient leurs activités avec
délectation des noms d un kiki chez vous
un os non mais vous avez peut-être
remarqué que
comment dire la première page de notre
site ne fait pas apparaître de signature
tout à fait et même si les articles sont
signés passe autour de moi être accusé
je ne sais pas quoi d'entretenir la
clandestinité mais c'est très facile de
vous joindre l'on doit la non maîtrise
est venu nous allons mais
chacun de nos articles est considéré
comme un article qui engagent notre
association alors évidemment il n'est
pas d'être discutée par l'ensemble des
adhérents sera impraticable
mais les l'ensemble des adhérents ou le
droit de dire là vous nous avez engagé
au moins a posteriori on déconne en
salles peuvent le faire et il devrait le
faire plus souvent dire bien donc ce
sont des articles qui sont des articles
d'un d'une association qui engage une
association donc le copain en question
qui qui se préoccupe avec délectation
par le nombre d'associations sanaa
auquel aucune apparence et l'associé
donc l'oreille le comité orwell
écoutez c'est
allez on va faire un deuxième un
deuxième écran d'amabilités 1 ou 2
sourire sarcastique
voilà des journalistes il faut un comité
pour défendre le pluralisme
très bien moi je trouve tous les comités
qui défendent le pluralisme surtout dans
l'état où il se trouve c'est une très
très bonne idée et qui se pose en
victime
je simplifie d'une censure qui fait
qu'on ne les entendrez par la police de
la pensée voilà mais le problème c'est
qu'on les entend partout tous peut-être
pas tous enfin on va me dire que je
retiens quelques noms parce que c'est
pas moi qui ai suivi cette affaire que
jenny bastié ou
natacha polony soit privé d'antenne de
parole de conditions d'expression etc
fasse partie des minorités
opprimées
s'il s'agit de la minorité parmi les
journalistes disons que c'est une
minorité parmi d'autres il ya plein de
minorité parmi les journal tient pas il
faut l'espérer il ya des la minorité des
journalistes précaires il ya la mine kyo
que le on n'entend jamais il ya l'ami
d'autorité des journalistes même
d'extrême droite qu'on entend peu enfin
beaucoup quand même il ya la minorité
des gens qui ont plutôt une sensibilité
de gauche de gauche il ya tout et à la
minorité des journalistes qu'il faudrait
faire un travail de journaliste et pas
de commentateurs donc le pluralisme
c'est ce ce comité pose en victime d'une
défense du 2 2 comment dire du
pluralisme mais d'un pluralisme quand
même un peu riquiqui c'est à dire de la
minorité qu'il représente peu aprue peu
ou prou même s'il peut y avoir
une certaine diversité parmi eux vous
pensez pas que c'est une pointe de
diamant pour un petit peu une pointe de
diamant ou un bouclier pour protéger un
petit peu pour lancer une dynamique de
précaires relèvent la tête non non non
il en une en vous avez vu notre
interview de natacha polony je les ai
pas vus j'ai regardé le début pour voir
quelles quel genre de job vous faisiez
qui ne fait pas de job leur ouïe ouïe
nommé car dès qu'on lui touche dès qu'on
touche à son activité devient sus élan
d'originalité on n'est pas journaliste
on fait ça tous voilà bon c'est pas un
job c'est une activité services mobiles
adore mettre les doigts dans les
cerveaux des souris bon et donc
donc je peux pas j'ai pas regardé dans
le détail j'ai vu simplement qu'ils
avaient organisé un débat où
participaient la claque la crème ou une
partie de la crème des éditocrates que
l'on entend que l'on voit que l'on lit à
peu près partout bien c'est pas ça le
pluralisme mais si je peux me permettre
moi qui ai été invité à cette ouverture
du colloque vous avez vu qu'on a un
petit peu des personnalités atypiques
c'était certes tenus par est organisé
par des journalistes qui n'ont pas
besoin de visibilité par contre
le public y avait la parole
d'une façon très acide et le public a pu
s'exprimer et transmettre des choses
aussi à cette garde prétorienne de
l'information je vous trouve ça un peu
dur moi j'ai même pas dix gardes
prétoriennes de l'information c'est vous
qui l'avez je garde l'expression il est
quand même intéressante bah oui vous
avez dit garde prétorienne de
l'information
écoutez je vais vous donner un
exemple et un seul
pour commencer vous savez combien de
fois acrimed a été invité en 20 ans dans
un grand média 0 ah non ça c'est faux 2
une fois une fois qu'elle était médias
c'était une émission de ce soir ou
jamais qui est déjà une émission disons
atypique bien où l'un d'eux ne des
membres de notre association a été
invité je ne me souviens plus exactement
quel est le thème de l'un de l'émission
et où nous avons accepté d'aller parce
qu'on est de très exigeant tout
simplement parce que c'est une émission
dans lesquelles les conditions
d'expression sont à peu près convenable
c'est à dire que chaque année il ya
peut-être beaucoup trop de personnes sur
le plateau mais chaque personne qui est
sur le plateau d'i speedy dispose de
plus de 30 secondes pour dire ce qu'il a
à dire on est bien là non ouais à ce
formidable on va faire un six heures
d'accord
vous trouvez qu'ils auraient dû vous
invitez
non je pense que c'est un symptôme c'est
un symptôme oui j'avais goûté en existe
depuis 20 ans ne dispose une audience
relativement significative même si elle
est minoritaire c'est pour ça que j'ai
là du moins la communauté a décidé voilà
où nous ne répondrons pas à toutes les
invitations
nous nous avons nous sommes fixé un
certain nombre de règles
de ce pro sur vivre au milieu de ce oui
ce n'est pas son personnel parce que
comment dire la contestation quel qu'en
soit le contenu la forme est l'origine
peut très bien être transformés en
produits médiatiques comme les autres
bon on n'a pas envie d'entrer dans le
cirque médiatique comme une information
de faits divers voyez vous avez le fait
divers de telles copies ou tel copains
d'acrimed a eu droit ces trente secondes
sur bfm tv
voilà nous on n'est pas de nous dans la
situation si vous voulez
je prenais du recul vous regardez le
temps mais
comment dire on peut tout on n'est quand
même pas sectaire on est intransigeant
mais pas sectaire
c'est une qualité que nous partageons
voilà
qu'un représentant de que des
travailleurs en lutte en lutte et c'est
de se saisir d'un micro quand on accepte
de lui tendre pour essayer de faire
connaître des motivations de sa lutte ça
va de soi qu'un parti politique qu'ils
jugent utile de présenter des candidats
un présidentialisme pas s'amuser à
boycotter les émissions b l'ailé d
interview matinale de france inter ou
d'europe 1 ou 2 sais pas quoi bien sous
prétexte que l'interviewer et
est à sens unique bon parfois c'est
difficile parce que quand on doit pas
aller une interview avec elkabbach et
que l'on sait que c'est un des
éditorialistes les plus partisans qu'ils
soient depuis maintenant des dizaines et
dizaines d'années il faut avoir les
reins solides pour accepter de ce
théâtre là mais on peut comprendre qu'un
parti politique bien en campagne nous on
n'est pas dans cette situation là on n'a
pas besoin d'une visibilité médiatique à
tout prix on n'a pas besoin de se tirer
une balle dans le pied on n'a pas besoin
de tenir des propos simplistes
que l'on dira simplice parce qu'on nous
a accordé 30 secondes pour les énoncés
même là même la regarder
on dispose d'un temps d'expression très
long mais on balise thème des des
questions tellement nombreuses et bon
j'accepte j'accepte la loi du genre je
sais pas une rue un reproche que
nécessairement ce qui a pu être dit sur
chacune d'elles était nécessairement
simplifiée bien à vous imaginer un
micro-trottoir casca crimen pense de la
dernière décision du csa avantage avec
internet ce que l'on dispose d'un temps
dispose d'un temps mais surtout
maintenant avec internet on a des
communautés et ses communautés
s'endurcissent grâce je vais dire avec
nos interviews notre communauté arrive à
ce que vous avez dit va se recouper dans
une autre de nos interviews c'est à dire
l'arborescence de nos interviews fait
émerger une connaissance globale c'est à
dire que même si on balaye large comme
on a plus de 35 heures d'interviews
notre communauté pioche et arrive à se
forger son esprit chrétien oui
je risque une hypothèse agrément je le
fais à titre personnel parce que
malheureusement pas encore eu le temps
d'en discuter parce collectivement
il ya deux risques dans le développement
des nouvelles technologies dont on a peu
parlé mais finalement
le premier c'est une fragmentation
considérable des sources d'information
alors on peut se dire le journal
télévisé de 20h à l'époque de l'eau et
rtf où il existait une seule chaîne de
télé bon d'accord c'était pas fragmenté
mais c'était pas enthousiasmant répond
on pourrait dire non plus que c'était
franchement pluralise diversifié bien
mais là il ya une tellement une telle
fragmentation de l'offre une telle
fragmentation des supports
que
les conduit une telle diffusion de
l'information
soumise à des algorithmes
qui sont à goris mme d'audience que il
ya une déperdition de l'information tout
à fait considérable c'est qu'on ne sait
plus on sait de plus en plus
difficilement sur qui sur quoi les gens
s'informent parce que nous on continue à
penser que c'est d'ailleurs parce que
ces sont des chiffres que la
fréquentation des journaux télévisés de
tf1 et france 2 le soir sur les taux
sont de l'ordre je connais j'ai pas la
mémoire des chine mais de plus de 10
millions c'est pas tout à fait
l'audience d'acrimed et ce n'est pas
encore tout à fait là votre nom ça vient
ça vient charge l'issue puis vous
souhaite bien dont fait partie d'une
alliance de nos blogueurs qui a fait
plus de 5 millions de followers oui oui
mais cédé 5 millions de followers
donc c'est des trucs qu'on peut lever et
envoyé sur un ministère sa fiche y
croyez on verra jeu va vous interviews
et iasi qu'un jour on vous interroge
mais à visage masqué
ah oui on peut accepter ça marche
relèvent le défi avec eux avec lui mais
avec amical avec un casque et un
mouchoir sur la figure un masque devient
vient l'emmène chez plantations juste
terminée parce qu'autrement c'est des
idées qui s'enchaînent les unes aux
autres et aussi retrouve plus du tout je
vous en prie simple bien un risque de
fragmentation et surtout un risque de
feu pour utiliser la formule
de jacques chirac dans sa campagne
électorale de 2002 ont géré comme un
risque de fracture sociale c'est-à-dire
des médias pauvres pour les pauvres et
des médias riches pour une grille et des
médias riches pour les riches et c'est
pour nous et on a un regard critique
quand même sur ce que l'on fait c'est
c'est pour nous un problème
regardez là nous on fait un média riche
pour les pauvres
il faut vérifier
faut vérifier franchement vous ne pouvez
qu'être quoi que quelle que soit votre
activité vous pouvez pas rêver d'élise
est aujourd'hui avec les grands matière
par exemple sur l'information
internationale
c'est faux ah bon on m'a suffisamment de
contacts à l'étranger on va le don
d'ubiquité des copains reporter de
guerre qui seront sur le terrain que ce
soit en afrique que ce soit en arctique
en ce moment j'ai deux potes reporter de
guerre un article que je connais
personnellement je peux pas rivaliser
non mais par contre je peux bien
l'attaqué je suis comme toi qui vois
washington et vous pouvez enfoncer un
coin même coin tant mieux le bras va pas
non mais le risque global existe quand
même tout à fait c'est à dire direct
matin autour de direct matin
pour les gens qui travaillent et qui le
prennent au passage avant d'aller au
moins en région parisienne prendre le
portable est black lips auxerre à la
bras là et puis par un peu
d'autodérision
le formidable
magazine d'acrimed médias critiques bien
diffusé à exemplaires ou le monde
diplomatique à au moins une durée
d'usagé importante parce qu'il faut un
mois pour le lire donc c'est parfait
mais ni les acteurs du monde
diplomatique ni nous mêmes un moindre
degré nous sommes totalement dupe de
comment dire du fait qu'on appartient
quand même on au club de ceux qui sont
relativement richement doté soit du
point de vue culturel soit du point de
vue social soit du point de vue militant
c'est à dire qu'ils ont des formes
d'engagement qui lui fait beau lot les
font participer à la vie sociale
politique etc voilà
hélas les rapports de force sont
peut-être peut-être je te le dit tout à
l'heure que je voulais pas être prophète
mais les rapports de force sont
peut-être en train de se dégrader
considérablement il n'y a pas de
fatalité ya pas de fatalité c'est pour
ça que nous définissons outre la
question du csa puisqu'on un peu on a
émis étaient toutes les questions
d'autres propositions sur la
transformation des médias quelles sont
elles
invitées mois nouveau je pense que alors
on va passer à la dernière question
parce que ça fait pratiquement l'erreur
qu'on tourne c'est vrai je vais rifains
je m'ennuie pas avec vous c'est bon lait
merci et nous non plus et la dernière
question qu'on a l'habitude de poser sur
notre chaîne youtube s'est donné un
conseil pour les jeunes générations où
je n'ai pas une question c'est un
commandement
c'est un conseil ou un commandement non
nous vous en vous demande avec le
congrès de donner à gauche au monde
henri malheur je veux nous exigeons un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose qui va
être immortel impérissable c'est à dire
que même après votre mort vous retrouvez
là je crois que vous ne vous attendez
pas la réponse mais c'est l'associé vous
inquiétez pas on a eu des réponses vous
et je vous dis un
conseil aux jeunes générations
nous savons très bien que vous n'êtes
pas riche et que vous êtes socialement
très souvent mal portants mais
participer à la souscription d'un cri
mais nous avons besoin de 60000 euros
pour pouvoir poursuivre notre activité
et puis de temps en temps quand vous
avez le temps
lisez ce que nous écrivons
voulais rajouter quelque chose merci
merci henri malheur au plaisir
[Musique]
le